when I first saw this article in the
guardian in a brief moment of hopeless
optimism I thought based on the title
that it might be making a valid and
important point and here's the title
when I became a mother I lost my body
and realized it never belonged to me now
that's actually true as a woman your
body does not belong entirely to you
as a man your body doesn't belong
entirely to you you are not an
autonomous Island floating alone out in
the sea neither am I I have
responsibilities I have obligations I I
owe myself to others especially my
family and when I say I that includes my
body as I I am not in this life
separable from my body there is no I
that exists separate of my body they're
one in the same I am my body this is
this is why bodily autonomy is a
misnomer it's a myth it's incoherent to
be entirely autonomous in your body is
to be entirely autonomous in your person
as these are one and the same
but no person is autonomous we all have
duties that transcend whatever claims we
might want to make to autonomy like
there are lots of things that you can be
forced to do
and if you are forced to do it then your
body is forced to do it because again
you exist and your body exists they're
wanting to say you are your body
um and this is especially true if you're
a mother and a wife or a father and a
husband
though it's also true of everybody no
matter their their relationship status I
that is my mind soul and body all
together they're a package deal uh I get
up every morning and uh care for my
family I go to work I I do things around
the house I I I pick up the sleeping
three-year-old from the couch and I
carry her to bed I lift heavy things
that need to be lifted whether
physically or metaphorically I do all of
this and many other things with my body
as my body and I have no rights legally
or morally to just up and declare one
day that I don't want to do anything for
anyone else I don't want to be forced to
do anything uh even for my own kids or
my wife that would make me neglectful
and derelict and criminally so
there are also laws and other legal
obligations that I'm expected to fulfill
and Obey with my body as I do everything
with my body as as my body because again
I am my body once again these These are
obligations that supersede any notion of
autonomy
so so yes it's true in this sense that
my body does not belong only to me as I
myself do not belong only to myself I am
not a self-created being existing only
for whatever purpose I decide and
neither is the author of this article
and I thought that maybe that was the
realization she had come to and decided
to write about
but I was wrong
instead the author a feminist named the
Mana Amanda Monte has written not a
revelation that she is a child of God
who exists for a higher purpose but
rather a lament that everybody in the
world including her children especially
her children are using and victimizing
her this is not an expression of
motherly love but a long weird and
weirdly sexualized wine it is in other
words exactly what you expect from a
feminist uh let me read just a few
passages quote when my daughter learned
to walk she began following me around
our apartment into the bathroom while I
showered studying my naked body into the
bedroom where I dressed regarding my
baggy underwear with curiosity it was
the fall of the 2016 election and as she
watched my utterly changed body though
her eyes were kind and questioning I
could not help but recall the faces of
men who had at various points in my life
scrutinized my body with approval or
reproach that year her nascent voice
full of innocent inquisitiveness also
began to drown out my own thoughts as I
was reminded of the many men who had
spoken over me all my life motherhood I
found early on
was triggering
now this is the theme that she returns
to over and over again she compares her
young children to the men that she had
unpleasant sexual experiences with and
these comparisons get even more
disturbing and specific as the article
goes on listen to this quote when I got
home at the end of a long day working at
the daycare I let my daughter have her
way with me exhausted for many sleepless
nights tending to my baby I lay on the
floor of her room let her Pat me to
sleep I did as I was told eyes closed
half awake when the game was finished
she ascended me requesting books on laps
a ride around the apartment more breasts
I called on I called on coping
mechanisms old coping mechanisms in my
20s I had learned methods for
disassociating I studied corners of the
room while men got themselves off inside
me I listened to their heavy breathing
calculating how much longer moaning here
and there to help them along moving my
hips methodically or going limp I had
cleaved myself from my body long ago
this was nothing new
now it's bad enough that she needs to
develop a coping mechanism to deal with
the awful burden of spending a few
minutes with her daughter even worse she
directly Compares this time with her
daughter to other times when men and I
quote got themselves off inside her
and she keeps going on this note quote
most of our sexual encounters are spent
in calculations the feminist theorist
and co-founder of the wages for work
movement Sylvia federici writes of women
we sigh SOB gasp pant jump up and down
in bed but in the meantime our minds
keep calculating how much how much of
ourselves can we give before we lose or
undersell ourselves how much will we get
in return
motherhood was filled with an agonizing
sense of calculation of waiting of
pushing my body to the brink of what it
could take of counting down the minutes
and of doing things I did not want to do
repeatedly I tried to make myself into
an object that was accommodating and
agreeable but over time I found myself
wondering whether life for some women
was just a series of moments in which we
grit our teeth and watch the clock
now there's a lot more like this it's
all woven throughout the article which
apparently the author has adapted from
an entire book she wrote on the subject
and she doesn't seem to understand why
normal people consider it extremely
disturbing to compare play time with
your daughter with your toddler to an
awkward hookup you had with some guy
she doesn't understand this because to a
feminist this is second nature they
sexualize absolutely everything they
can't help themselves I mean they see
sexual competition and sexual tension
and sexual conquest and sexual Mind
Games in everything they do everything
that happens to them everything is
sexual all the time this is the kind of
neurosis Neurosis that they bring into
motherhood and it's why there are
children invariably grow up to despise
them and justifiably so you know one
thing we're always talking about over
here is uh delicious All-American meat
do you know what uh we all like even
more when that American meat is free
that's why we love good ranchers they
Source the best meat in America and
deliver it right to your door even
better right now they're offering two
years of free ground beef to anyone who
subscribes that's a 480 value I can tell
you the ground beef is delicious as well
I use it in my chili I only put the best
meat in my chili just made some uh this
past Sunday and uh it was the the best
chili of all time as every batch of
chili I make is not only are you going
to get the best cuts of meat from a
trusted 100 American Source company but
you're also going to lock in your price
for two whole years when you subscribe
to any of their boxes that's two years
of free high quality ground beef and a
locked in price no other Meat Company
guarantees you 100 American Meat and a
locked in price that's because no one
else is good ranchers you can save on
your beef chicken and pork by locking in
your price today every single Steakhouse
quality cut is individually wrapped and
flash frozen to make Meal Time easy
subscribe to good ranchers to get a
guaranteed price and a trusted 100
American source for your favorite Cuts
go to goodranchors.com and use my code
Walsh for 25 off and free ground beef
for two years remember subscribe to any
box to lock in your price on America's
best mate for two whole years as well
that's goodranchers.com today and use my
code walls for over 500 in savings
subscribe to good ranchers American Meat
delivered Grand Canyon University is an
affordable private Christian University
that is located in beautiful Phoenix
Arizona has a vibrant and expansive
campus ranked top 20 in the country
according to niche.com praise for its
culture and Community giving an impact
GCU integrates a free market system and
a welcoming Christian worldview
Perspective into over a 320 academic
programs with more than 260 programs
online as of March 2023 you can earn
your bachelor's Masters or doctoral
degree where you can engage with faculty
and connect with your own University
counselor who takes a personalized
approach for your success finds your
purpose at Grand Canyon University
private Christian affordable visit
gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
well the article isn't all just this
weird wildly out of place and
inappropriate sex talk there's also
quite a lot of melodramatic complaining
this is the other specialty of a
feminist self-marded them putting
themselves up on the cross and she
climbs up on many crosses all throughout
the article a quick sample quote
avoiding my own needs and desires have
become a method of survival what I
wanted in early motherhood more than
anything was to feel as though I fully
inhabited and had my body but all the
ideas about how I should act as a mother
how I should respond to near constant
requests demands for attention volatile
emotions hands down my shirt smooshing
my face not to mention the complete
dissolution of self I experienced
outside my role as mother made me feel
so small I struggled with the
physicality of caring for children which
was worsened by the isolation alienation
I felt as friends and colleagues
disappeared and as my husband and I
despite our best efforts fell into a
rather traditional division of labor in
the home
she also complains that her children are
ravenous beasts who devour her reading
quote Marguerite de Ross wrote that in
motherhood a woman gives her body over
to her child until they're on her as
they might be on a hill in a garden they
devour her they hit her they sleep on
her though my child's touch began as
something invited as long as I lost
control of my life every request every
tug felt like a violation she lets
herself be devoured to Ross writes
nothing like this happens with fathers I
didn't want to be devoured I tried very
hard not to be devoured I would not say
that I let it happen
and she ends on this note quote at least
on the surface the love I shared with my
young children felt uncomplicated by
gender it was my sudden lonely
housewifery that felt forced compulsory
staged inescapable and recognizable I
was living a life that seemed as the
Ross put it to have been written down
and described already and is with my
early sexual encounters the experience
of getting what I wanted was immediately
tainted by what I hadn't known before
consenting
okay so we see here all of the Hallmarks
of feminism one as already mentioned is
the compulsion to sexualize everything
another is a fundamental
misunderstanding about bodily autonomy
namely the feminist thinks that bodily
autonomy absolute bodily autonomy can
actually exist or should exist and it
can't and
yet another is the insistence on being a
victim in all things in all
circumstances no matter what notice how
she describes all of her sexual
encounters as horrific drudgeries that
she had to cope with and endure
miserably
that's not because the encounters were
non-consensual she did consent but she
is still a victim of them somehow she's
the victim of everything
she's the victim of everything that she
herself does
she's the victim even of her own
children's affection
she is cringing through life waiting for
every moment to be done so that she can
get to the next moment and complain
about that one too
she presents herself as an utterly
insufferable person a bitter irritable
petulant harpy this is the picture she
paints of herself and I am quite sure
that it's accurate
now
it is true of course that women carry
their own special burdens they have
their own pains their own suffering it's
true that motherhood can be challenging
sometimes profoundly so it's true that
being constantly needed by your children
constantly the focus of their attention
can at times be draining and exhausting
nobody denies any of that
but
you don't get any credit for facing
those challenges or any sympathy for the
suffering you experience if all you do
is complain about it
if you have a terrible attitude the
whole time if you are whiny and
miserable and awful to be around
then you receive no gratitude from your
loved ones because you don't deserve any
okay you don't deserve it
you know we usually say children should
be grateful to their parents but if
their parents are just miserable and
resentful all the time you know what
your children should be grateful for you
they shouldn't to be grateful for what
this is what happens with a woman like
Amanda and there are many such cases she
experiences some of the ordinary
hardships and difficulties that come
with being a mother and a wife and she
becomes immediately bitter about it and
then even more bitter that our children
and husband aren't appreciative and
grateful for her sacrifices but what are
they supposed to appreciate you've met
every Challenge and hardship with the
worst possible attitude in the worst
possible way and you have brought misery
and anger and resentment into the home
we want them to thank you for
I mean you should be apologizing to them
not expecting a thank you
you don't get credit for simply
experiencing a hardship everyone does
that like the fact that you're just
experiencing it
we all have to experience hardship
that's there's nothing special about
that you get credit for enduring it with
some semblance of dignity and strength
and courage
which doesn't seem that Amanda ever has
in her life
and this is a point that lots of people
and not just feminists need to
understand we all have crosses that we
bear
and you can choose to carry yours with
Grace
or you can whine and cry and milk it for
every ounce of pity you can get out of
it and if you choose the latter option
then it's all for nothing
you see suffering is an opportunity it's
an opportunity to become stronger to
gain wisdom to gain perspective
but you squander that opportunity if you
whimper and moan and gripe the whole
time
now you still have to suffer
but but you aren't even becoming a
better person through it you're actually
becoming a worse person it's the worst
of all worlds
so you get the suffering that we all do
but none of the benefits none of the
bright side
you've only become smaller and weaker in
the process
until you become an exceptionally small
and weak person like our friend Amanda
who
is now today of course
canceled if you'd like to see what else
I have to say you can access my full
show by going to dailywire.com or by
going to the Matt wall Show Twitter page
hope to see you there Godspeed